donc on vous l'avait annoncé on va en
parler LR LR le score de François-Xavier
Bellamy il est assez sans appel le 8,2%
les couteaux seront donc deux sorties
sans doute ce soir au bureau politique
des républicains avec cette question
dans tous les esprits Laurent Wauquiez
doit-il va-t-il partir
pas sur que il reçoivent le président de
l'air beaucoup de soutiens ce soir en
tout cas pas celui de Valérie Pécresse
la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France lancé l'offensive dès ce
matin en l'écoute s'il devait
démissionner je crois pas que ce soit
qui vous ne le pensez pas dites le moi
je crois pas que ce soit une question
personnelle ou c'est voilà
on ne peut pas le dire autrement c'est
une question très personnelle
si j'étais à sa place et vu la situation
sans doute je le ferai mais le sujet
n'est pas une question personnelle le
sujet c'est celui de la ligne politique
de la droite moi je crois qu'il ne faut
pas avoir une stratégie de
rétrécissement mais une stratégie
d'élargissement si j'étais à sa place je
le ferai nous vivaient les Pécresse un
peu le coup de pied de l'âne Nicolas
Bouzou oui je crains que ce soit trop
tard et je le regrette parce que moi je
pense que c'est très important d'avoir
un parti de droite et de et de centre
droit parce que le grand danger de la
situation actuelle en mettant Emmanuel
Macron face au rassemblement national de
mon point de vue en tout cas c'est que
le rassemblement national peut gagner
donc je pense que c'est une situation
qui est extrêmement extrêmement
dangereuse
je pense que c'est un peu tard parce que
en effet le créneau que Valérie Pécresse
par exemple incarne de fait je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous il est
pris par Emmanuel Macron qui mène une
politique de droite
sur les questions économiques c'est une
politique de droite sur les questions
d'immigration c'est une politique de
droite sur la question d'éducation c'est
une politique de droite donc il y a très
peu d'espace je pense que cet espace
aurait pu être pris au début c'est à
dire au fond il y a beaucoup d'angle
morts dans la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron moi je la trouve plutôt bonne
mais il y a quand même beaucoup d'angle
morts sur les questions de dépenses
publiques par exemple et je pense que
c'est vraiment un sujet qui aurait pu
être investi avec beaucoup d'efficacité
par la droite et par le centre mais pour
ça il aurait fallu un discours qui soit
un discours qui porte justement sur
l'économie qui soit crédible sur les
questions économiques et qui
réconcilient les trois droites dont je
parlais tout à l'heure et si je puis
prendre mon exemple personnel moi
j'avais toujours voté vous le savez au
centre droit et là je n'ai pas j'ai voté
pour la liste Renaissance tout
simplement parce que avec
François-Xavier belémite et quelqu'un
que pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
considérations mais ce ne sont pas mes
idées
voilà notamment sur le plan sociétal je
ne partage aucune de ces idées et
j'avais toujours voté j'avais soutenu
Alain Juppé à la primaire c'est quand
même un courant de la droite qui a
existé voilà et donc je pense que cette
stratégie a été absolument suicidaire
vous connaissez bien aussi la droite et
la sociologie
l'exemple de Nicolas Bouzou oui je
trouve que c'est très intéressant en
plus son exemple personnel illustre tout
à fait ce qu'on vient de dire c'est à
dire que Emmanuel Macron a à au fond
pris
la place de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
cette droite modérée cette droite exige
cardienne enfin qui a vraiment évolué
depuis et donc ça infirme complètement
la stratégie Pécresse là c'est au
contraire la seule possibilité qui
resterait pour le parti des républicains
c'est au contraire d'essayer mais avec
le risque évidemment de se faire manger
par
le rassemblement national c'est
d'essayer de constituer une sorte de
grand disons alors très conservateurs
c'est un peu ce qui va se passer par
exemple en Italie on va je sais pas si
on va en parler mais on voit très très
bien que Salvini a réussi à constituer
un immense pôle disons populiste de
droite que Berlusconi s'est complètement
effondré d'ailleurs c'est un peu les
mêmes scores que les républicains en
France on est autour de 8% c'est assez
bizarre comme si en vérité la droite
libérale sur le plan économique
n'arrivait pas à se raccorder avec la
droite disons conservatrice sur le plan
des valeurs et qu'au fond la majorité de
la droite
libérale fait d'abord passer ces
intérêts de classe si on peut dire bon
une sorte de vote économique je vais
utiliser un dessin de manière polémique
une expression marxiste mais comme je
l'avais Jean Jaurès à côté j'ai pensé
que on était on était en bonne en bonne
compagnie non c'est intéressant parce
que par exemple le 16e arrondissement a
voté en plutôt
donc on voit très bien qu'au fond il y a
une sorte de mutation peut-être aussi
dans une part importante de la
bourgeoisie elle se modernise elle elle
reste très très au fait de ces intérêts
économiques et elle se désintéresse un
peu de ce qui a été finalement le le
fond de commerce de François-Xavier
Bellamy alors même que on peut penser
qu'il y avait des des des fortes raisons
d'évoquer un certain nombre de ces de
ces thèmes donc pour l'instant je pense
qu'en effet parce que en plus c'est les
européennes la l'échec de de cette
stratégie et patente on verra par la
suite parce que d'entre vous au début
mettront plus de deux ans et demi avant
de pouvoir Maxime
juste la réponse à la question qu'on
vous pose sur le Figaro.fr les en France
les parties traditionnelles de la droite
et de la gauche pardon sont-ils condamné
69% d'entre vous pensent que oui donc
plus des deux tiers Maxime dégagée
de la droite donc
dans la question
on peut faire on peut faire le parallèle
puisque effectivement on est un peu vécu
nous cette situation là en 2017 je ce
que nous avons décidé de faire en tout
cas pour cette élection européenne c'est
précisément d'essayer de nous
transcender alors ça réussit pas réussi
mais en tout cas en étant capable de
pouvoir construire une offre un peu
nouvelle et de concilier de manière plus
importante qu'on avait fait jusqu'à
présent la question écologique et la
question sociale on y reviendra
j'imagine tout à l'heure qu'on parlera
des vers moi il me semble que la
situation dans laquelle est la droite
est extrêmement compliquée on voit bien
qu'il y a une impasse stratégique
puisque moi je ne vois pas comment
est-ce qu'ils arrivent même aux
municipales à s'articuler avec la
République en marche alors qu'on a posé
il y a un instant les sujets de
convergence qui sont les leurs il y a
évidemment aujourd'hui un néant
idéologique parce que on voit bien que
sur toute une série de questions ils ne
sont pas capables de pouvoir poser on va
dire une démarche et une vision
cohérente de la société on voit aussi
que ils sont quelquefois tiraillés vous
vous avez vu et moi je m'en suis
félicité qu'ils étaient capables de
voter avec la gauche qu'on a
privatisation de la DP mais qui est pas
un élément nul à mon sens d'ailleurs
Valérie Pécresse si opposant parce que
c'est la seule à droite qui était
favorable à la Privat privatisation de
la DP et dans le même temps
effectivement étant favorable est-ce que
il y ait une dette publique qui
considère qui qui constitue et bien la
seule boussole d'une action
gouvernementale donc on va bien
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont toute une série
de difficultés je ne vais pas donc leur
donner des conseils il me semble
cependant que au-delà au-delà de la
question de on va dire du positionnement
de curseur de la droite sur une un
échiquier de valeur il y a aussi
certainement quelque chose à aller
chercher chez eux sur la question des
territoires il me semble que ce qui est
aussi distingue potentiellement la
droite
de la gauche traditionnelle de la
République en marche c'est précisément
son rapport au territoire qui est quand
même une question qui a émergé dans les
ces derniers mois avec toutes les toutes
les séries de crises qu'on a connues
donc je serai un atout pour elle je
voyage territorial enfin l'implantation
et je le suis pas et je les combats
effectivement une droite une droite des
territoires quelques commentaires
c'est
cette question le commentaire c'est le
pseudo de notre internaute LR a voulu
faire du RN mais les électeurs ont
préféré l'original c'est clair l'eau
nous dit Wauquiez qui a voulu jouer au
FN il a fait fuir des millions
d'électeurs citoyens payants il ne reste
plus qu'à aller le droite DLR et
Dupont-Aignan a rejoindre le RN oui
c'est ça et babino la ligne ultra
conservatrice de vos quais est un fiasco
total il a voulu chasser sur les terres
de Le Pen il a échoué il doit s'en aller
il y a un problème Wauquier Emmanuel
Rivière il y a clairement un problème de
ligne et ce que je trouve qu'illustrer
parfaitement ce que vous avez dit les
uns les autres c'est quand on regarde
les les enquêtes qui ont été publiées
d'analyse du vote consécutivement votre
hier soir et puis une base électorale
pour les républicains
les ouvriers votent pour le
rassemblement national en majorité et
pas du tout pour les républicains il
serait parti dans les autres forces
politiques notamment à gauche les cadres
professionnels intellectuels votent pour
en main les retraités ne votent plus
pour les républicains les retraités vont
d'abord en
rassemblement national ça c'est
extrêmement enfin c'est extrêmement
nouveau c'est à dire que les retraités
ne veulent c'est une clientèle
électorale la droite et quand on regarde
ce que j'ai fait assez modestement et
modérément mais quand on regarde la
carte électorale on s'interroge aussi
sur la capacité à avoir en cours
aujourd'hui des filles alors ça pose
vraiment la question des municipales et
par rapport à cette perspective alors
peut-être parce que j'ai pas beaucoup
dormi mais je voulais un scénario
politique fiction peut-être que je vous
soumets puis tant pis je pense qu'il y
aura un certain nombre de maires la
droite les républicains sont gagnantes
en position de force municipale Coran
intérêt ils auront raison à jouer
beaucoup sur leur équation personnelle
et a pas trop avancé l'étiquette en
marche qui a envie d'avoir des élus et
pas forcément d'aller en frontal là où
vous serez quand même compliqué sur des
mains aura peut-être intérêt justement à
jouer dans le fond on risque d'avoir un
peu de mal à dire au mois de mars qui a
gagné qui a perdu et à quel camp il faut
attribuer les villes voilà c'est mon
scénario politique fiction c'est très
intéressant je pensais à quelqu'un en
particulier puisque il y a eu la semaine
dernière donc
[Musique]
et l'eau nous dit enfin si elle est
rejoint le RN il perdront les trois
quarts des électeurs qui leur reste